reaction this evening to a story our  i-team first broke earlier this week  about henderson leaders possibly jumping  the line to get vaccinated a spokeswoman  for the city had confirmed elected  officials were able to get vaccinated  the same day as first responders the  southern nevada health district  confirmed  it should not have been in that first  group now a henderson  senior who has been advocating for  nevadans in her age group  to have access to the vaccine spoke with  the i-team's vanessa murphy  older residents my age group we should  be  some of the first people in line and to  hear about  someone else basically cheating the  system really makes me mad  shirley bryce says she's 66 years of age  she's frustrated with the slow pace of  the vaccine rollout across our state  she started this facebook page vaccinate  nevada  now